cuando tenía 8 años aproximadamente yo
escuché por primera vez la palabra
identificar y eso fue para mí una
especie de sentencia de norma y puedo
decirles que desde entonces siempre ha
estado a mi cabeza retumbando
crecí pensando que todo lo debía
identificar
y eso se convirtió en una obsesión
luego asumí que identificar e identidad
era lo mismo hasta que comprendí que
esto es una práctica muy habitual de
todos nosotros y que sencillamente es
algo que por desconocimiento hacemos con
mucha frecuencia
muchos me han preguntado el porqué de mi
libro y estoy seguro que también lo
hacen para averiguar por qué mi obsesión
siempre contesto lo mismo esto obedece
cantidad de anécdotas en mi vida
como por ejemplo les cuento algunos
mi cédula de identidad yo tengo un
nombre totalmente distinto al que uso
para cosas legales
yo soy nieto de un español que aunque
tenía unos ojos azules y su acento lo
delataba es siempre decía que eres
español y había nacido en venezuela
por otro lado yo nací con una
o un problema auditivo que muchos años
me hizo creer que yo era una persona
diferente
y por otro lado
recuerdo que a mí me decíamos
y yo esto no lo entendía porque para los
que no saben no entienden eso es un
término solo venezolano que refiere a
las personas que son extranjeras o
rubias y yo así no me veía seguramente
esta anécdota lo tiene mucho de alguna
manera
y también seguro muchos se están
preguntando por qué esta fotografía
que obviamente no soy yo dice niña en la
parte inferior
pero les voy a contar una anécdota de
esto
esta persona de la foto es mi prima
rosalba
ambos tenemos la misma edad y cuando
éramos chicos y nos hacían fotos siempre
había alguien que preguntaba quién era
el de la fotografía
y ante esto recuerdo que mi madre un día
decide que todas las fotos las tienen
que poner cada vez que pregunta la
palabra niña o niño cosa que yo no
entendí porque no le ponía yale o
rosalba
ahí fue cuando escuché por primera vez a
mi madre decir
hay que identificar y creo que de ahí se
quedó para mí esta obsesión por
identificar
si algunos tienen curiosidad de quién
era este querubín a los 8 años de gente
que está ahí
pero quiero decirles algo sobre esto de
identidad que no es lo mismo identificar
y la palabra identidad
yo realicé mi trabajo del libro durante
10 años
muchos años
investigando sobre personajes que
resultan son emblemáticos de venezuela
una obsesión
que se convirtió
frecuente y que yo necesitaba además
establecer con esto esa diferencia entre
identidad identificar y lo que pude
lograr es para mí que tenía un concepto
errado simplemente establecer qué
identidad es esta el producto de la
decisión de pertenecer mientras que
identificar en aquello que usamos para
establecer la identidad
muchas veces hacemos algo de manera
errónea
y es que para parar identificar
hacemos una identidad inmediata y
ficticia de los personajes es decir lo
voy a hacer más gráfico para hacerlo más
cómodo muchas veces una persona puede
que vea a un árabe
con barba y enseguida dice que es un
terrorista y lo que hacemos es un
prejuicio cuando no necesariamente
la persona
ha decidido por tener barba que son sólo
una característica nunca quiere decir
que por tener barbas sea terrorista si
es no ha decidido ser o pertenecer ni
nunca
forma parte del terrorismo en ese caso
pero bueno lo que quiero decir con esto
que siempre hacemos un prejuicio
inmediato
sobre eso definirá a alguien pero por
suerte cuando nosotros aprendemos a
diferenciar esto
podemos también darle una identidad a
personas por cosas que han hecho en su
vida y así lo definan
un poco en mi libro esto fue lo que
quise hacer en mi obsesión a mucha gente
la quise identificar con un número que
formase parte de su identidad también de
su vida
y le voy a mostrar algunos ejemplos de
estos personajes qué
y yo entrevisté a algunos de ellos para
mi libro y como lo representaba teniendo
ya esto mucho más presente de como
nosotros a veces nos equivocamos a la
hora de catalogar o identificar pero por
ejemplo vayamos a mostrarle el primer
personaje
morochito rodríguez francisco morochito
rodríguez es el primer medallista de oro
olímpico venezolano
en 1968
les voy a dar otro ejemplo que seguro
para alguno va a ser más familiar
la primera
mujer que ganó el concurso de miss
universo
maritza sayalero en 1979 y por esto
ejemplo el que nosotros vamos
identificando y relacionando a las
personas
quien por ejemplo esto no lee una gran
referencia
un tema tan emblemático e importante
para todos los venezolanos como lo puede
ser para los mexicanos las mañanitas de
manuel ponce este tema fue compuesto por
luís cruz en 1953
otro punto significativo pueden ser por
ejemplo el saber qué
hay un venezolano que ganó en 1980 el
premio nobel de medicina que es baruj
benacerraf médico y científico
otro ejemplo es la arepa la arepa reina
pepiada
muy importante en la gastronomía
venezolana
y
quien no conoce la arepa reina pepiada
estaré para fue creada por el señor
heriberto álvarez en su familia en 1955
algunos no se pueden que lo sepan o no
pero esta fue creada en honor a la reina
de belleza susana wing en 1955 que fue
la primera miss mundo en este momento
y lo del término de pepiada viene de una
expresión de la época que referida
básicamente a aquello que estaba de muy
buen ver lo que estaba chévere como
decimos ahora y de ahí nace esto y como
nosotros es increíble podemos ir
asociando cosas nuestras a eso de la
identidad pero como no hablar de algo
tan emblemático nuestro como el empaque
de harina pan
un empaque muy significativo y un
producto muy importante para la
preparación de la arepa este empaque y
este diseño del empaque que ha sido muy
difícil que cambie con los años que
forma parte bien
contundente de lo que es una imagen para
venezuela
fue creado por un señor llamado marco
marco que pocos lo saben en 1962
y el señor marco marco increíblemente se
inspiró para hacer este empaque en la
luz sobras y leña carmen mirando
algo bien particular y que a lo mejor
alguno no sabía pero como una identidad
de otra cosa puede hacer luego
referencia a la identidad nuestra
que una luz sobras y leña fue la que
inspiró y luego hecho por un búlgaro que
se definía venezolano pero que hoy el
empaque harina pan es muy venezolano y
de eso nos sentimos mucho
de repente orgulloso de mostrar que eso
es un símbolo nuestro
cuándo
el adolescente cercano a la adolescencia
recuerdo que me operaron del oído por
sexta o séptima vez
esto debido a problemas de salud que
para ser desde muy niño y el problema
auditivo que siempre tengo
yo recuerdo que en la clínica en la
habitación de la clínica en una visita
médica con cables de mi cabeza que
parece un robot como ahora que he dicho
me siento igual un robot
en ese momento el médico se le ocurre
decirme que yo
era el hombre nuclear y tenía un oído
biónico
por supuesto para mí aquello no me dio
gracia ni lo entendí
la enfermera se apresuró rápidamente
aclarar que el señor en cuestión
interpretada por el email era el hombre
no nuclear que estaba en ese momento en
el televisor y yo seguí como si para mí
fuese igual
y mi asociación fue
yo de alguna manera ya sentía que tenía
un oído especial un oído avión y con
todos que por cierto si algún día me
llega a ver este doctor que sepa que el
del oído avión y con el hombre nuclear
si no la mujer maravilla pero yo
en este momento asociaba las cosas de
otra manera
mi asociación era imaginarme que cuando
tuviese edad quizá del hombre nuclear
tendría los ojos azules como mi abuelo
como él y quizás también esa manera de
obsesiva de mi abuelo identificarse con
ser venezolano
durante los el proceso postoperatorio
a mí me fascinaba la cantidad de visitas
que había en mi casa y que hablaban con
mi familia
los anécdotas que contaban la gente de
que hablaste que me hablaban y que para
mí era fantástico porque yo cada vez que
había un hombre necesitaba ponerle el
rostro
y es una obsesión que fue creciendo con
el tiempo creo que
a esa obsesión de
y llevarlo a ponerle rostro a todo
la persona que escuchaba y no conocía
fue lo que me inspiró de alguna manera
para hacer el libro pero estoy seguro
que el punto de inflexión lo produjo el
paro petrolero del 2002
en este momento yo sentí que estábamos
perdiendo cosas importantes y decidí
hacer algo por el país y quise hacer una
memoria donde estuviesen muchos
venezolanos que pues tan representativos
de nuestra identidad y es así como nace
el libro
yo aún tengo esta cosa de los personajes
que me obsesionan y cada vez que hay un
nombre nuevo para mí exponer un rostro
hoy quizás es mucho más básico cada uno
wikipedia pero la obsesión del libro fue
esto ponerle rostro a cada uno de estos
venezolanos y yo he nace identidad
venezuela mi rostro también
también con esa
necesidad de descubrir
de parte de cada uno que era una
pregunta que le dice a cada uno de los
entrevistados quiénes somos los
venezolanos fueron cientos de
venezolanos y quizás me sirvieron no
solamente para entender y explicar
quiénes somos los venezolanos sino para
buscar respuesta a mi propia pregunta de
qué es ser venezolano
entendí
que para hacer venezuela nosotros no
necesitamos
llenaron clics para que no fue conozca
por ejemplo a mí puede que no me gusta
la música folklórica
pero eso no quiere decir que sea meno
venezolano denunció venezolana como
puede que haya alguien que no le guste
la arepa y eso tampoco quiere decir que
no sea venezolano la identidad es una
decisión de cero pertenecer
y ahí es donde tenemos que entender que
es una decisión personal
entre esta curiosidad
[Música]
de quienes somos los venezolanos y de
cómo opinaron muchos de ellos sobre este
concepto y esta pregunta que le decía
cada uno de quienes somos los
venezolanos quiero que vean un ejemplo
de cuatro personas para que vean su
respuesta y como es importante siempre
tener en cuenta que la identidad es una
decisión personal
quienes somos los venezolanos recuerdo
esta pregunta hecha a un señor como
adrián
cuando le pregunté a él
quien ser venezolano su respuesta con
esta cosa de artista popular tira a su
casa y de que sea nacional ser
venezolano es comer arepas verdad el
béisbol y ser vivo qué curioso que a
veces nosotros entendemos que parte de
esa entidad la forma la gastronomía la
forma aquellas cosas en las que quizás
forman parte de nuestra cultura como un
juego de béisbol y quizás esa cosa con
la que uno se puede relacionar y sentir
como el ser vivo y esto es un
característica con la que casi siempre
se define al venezolano
otra explicación por ejemplo era
no tenemos una identidad definida sino
una identificación con aspectos de
nuestro ser
la queja es una elemento de identidad
así como lo es también la hallaca
fíjense
siempre hay que tener en cuenta lo que
es identificar identidad y muy bien los
cuentos que el filósofo el filólogo
guerrero donde hace ver que la queja es
una característica nuestra y que lo que
muchas veces
nosotros usamos con la identificamos son
elementos identitarios
otro ejemplo y esto además marca una vez
más que la identificación qué es lo que
siempre hacemos por entidad no es lo
mismo que identidad pero seguimos un
ejemplo también de elías pino iturrieta
historiador una cosa hacer lo que se
busca de la entidad y otra cosa es
parecer y generalmente el venezolano le
vende el alma al apareciendo en
lugar de haciendo
cuarto pino y una opinión
de sofía imber periodista gerente
cultural es venezuela nunca ha dejado de
ser un país solidario de brazos abiertos
eso es un carácter marcado en su adn
es interesante porque alguna manera como
nosotros muchas veces sentimos que nos
observan que somos solidarios
muy de hacer amigos familiares y es una
característica que aún predomina
durante una charla de montevideo en una
frase muy poderosa del filósofo
profesor pero filósofo uruguayo javier
masa y que dice si no nos narramos no
sabemos quiénes somos y no sabemos
quiénes somos no sabemos que tenemos que
hacer a ver hoy siento que nos cuesta
hablar de nuestra identidad
y lo hacemos muchas veces sin usar esta
palabra
lo hacemos excluyendo la quizás porque
es una palabra a la que le tenemos miedo
y porque de alguna manera ese miedo a la
incertidumbre el miedo al horror de
tener que reconocer la situación
política y social en la que vivimos
realmente
siempre tenemos como preguntas y
confusiones
cuando hacemos el tema de identidad
el miedo en halo que siempre nos estaba
paralizando cuando nos toca hablar de
quiénes somos nosotros
quiero comentarles también qué
la identidad
es una consecuencia del cambio y siempre
las personas cambiamos
yo creo que
cuando nosotros entendamos que lo de
identidad y el entender que es parte de
ser o pertenecer también obedece a
cambios
obedece a cambios porque cuando nosotros
decidimos ser o pertenecer a algo esto
es una decisión y de verdad tenemos que
tomar en cuenta que en esa decisión
nosotros cambiamos no somos siempre los
mismos
y que la identidad entonces es una
consecuencia de cambio y siempre las
personas y los países cambiamos
a veces
buscamos
un ejemplo de gente que ha tomado la
decisión de ceder o pertenecer
al país
y siempre existe la duda por ejemplo
de por qué nosotros criticamos a otras
personas si son o no son cuando si son o
no son venezolanos cuando hay personajes
muy emblemáticos
de nuestra cultura como jordan o sofía
imber soledad bravo incluso de quien
hablamos hace rato marco marcos que de
alguna manera reflejan características y
cuentos de nuestra identidad pero
fíjense ustedes que muchas de estas
personas no nacieron en venezuela
ninguno de los cuatro de la nación
venezuela y así muchas personas hay que
no nacieron en venezuela
y ellos decidieron sentir y reconocerse
venezolanos y cada vez siempre es así
entonces la pregunta de quién puede
decir lo contrario si así ellos lo
asumieron
durante
una conversación con víctor javier
uno de los organizadores de chacao
le hizo una pregunta que para mí
resultaba importante y es porque sigue
en venezuela y su respuesta fue
contundente
muy sencilla porque aquí soy alguien
es una vez más me demuestra que la
identidad es una decisión de ser y
pertenecer y lo que hizo víctor javier
fue una clara decisión de definir quién
es él como venezolano y ojo puede que
mañana francisco javier esté en otro
país se vaya pero él sigue siendo el
mismo venezolano si él así lo asumió
entendamos
la identidad
es una decisión personal
y esa decisión personal conlleva cambios
pero también
el entender y al exhortar que la
identidad es asumir lo bueno y lo malo
cuando nosotros asumimos y reconocemos
lo que tenemos
también podemos tomar la decisión de
cambiar lo que queremos
y cuando nosotros
decimos que no sabemos qué hacer
es porque no sabemos quiénes somos
bien lo dijo
el filósofo francés
jean-paul sartre
somos
lo que hacemos con lo que hicieron de
nosotros muchas gracias
bien
[Música]